all right clive
clive oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from uh jamaica
and you came to the us at what what age
oh well i came to the us uh uh
when uh i just about when i turned 18.
i um came with your family no actually i
i came by myself i had an
opportunity to work on a cruise line
um and um
by then you know we
we um you know the cruise line travel
different part of the world i i work on
five different uh ships which for the
same company
and of course we do the caribbean
cruises we do the europe and you know we
we had another two months to go home and
be with our family
but
um
after six years
i decided to um
to reside in the united states which i
my first stop was
miami i was in miami for a few years
then i uh relocate to california i've
been in california since then which is
goes back to the late 70s
and uh tell me about your childhood a
little bit you had both your parents
growing up yes
good childhood
i could you repeat that a good childhood
i would say yes you know back back
back home you know the way we were
raised is
it was more family
you know um
but poor you're very poor i'd say i
could remember the days when
i would go to school
no lunch
barefooted
you know when
like in summertime
the street would be so hot
uh what they put to surface the street
like what we call tar it's a black
thing then if you step on it melts when
it's done when it's hot
so you have to walk on in bushes
so you you your feet wouldn't get you
know scarred
so again i remember those days
growing up it's like i
i have to do better i mean
i mean i tried everything i make sure i
go to school every day
i i took up
what they call it back then was
cooking
these days it's cooling our hearts
so i um
i there was a was a
class that um they offer
cooking classes
i was the only male in the cooking class
because all men think that was a girl
thing
for me i see it as a profession way down
the road
so i learned how to do the things from
my mom and
you know it happened to pays off
i went to uh uh back home
go to cooking school
i went back home i went to cooking
school
i got my
internship at the hilton hotel
and after school i am they took me on as
a chef trainee
at hilton
for the next two years
i was with now until
uh the cruise line came to jamaica
wanted to hire people to work
i got hired
and
i was traveling for the next six years
and
here i am
yeah so you know i ended up at warner
brothers i worked for them for
many years
the same school i went to cia culinary
institute of america
i am
that was a very big boost in my career
um i became i got certified i'm a
certified executive chef which i'm clive
jackson cec
behind my name
most people don't understand that you
you just can't call yourself a chef and
be a chef you have to be a certified
chef to be a chef
but
it's common people call themselves chef
um
i'm one of the less than
to this point maybe less than 4 000
certified chef in the nation
which is in our world it's a big thing
big major thing
you know being a person of color
is a percentage of that
because i work hard i studied hard and i
accomplished a lot
you know i again went on to my
restaurants
[Music]
during that period time like this is
when my son
um
got killed
my son was the pride of my my life it
was
like i was living for myself it was my
first barn
and um where were you living at the time
i was living in l.a i was living in
south central area
uh how old was your son my son was 14 14
and
my son was we were supposed to be going
to on vacation it was during the
thanksgiving
weekend all day and um
i i my son called me said dad i need to
go and pick up some underwears t-shirts
whatever
for the trip it was thursday we were
leaving monday
i took off work
went to meet with him because again my
first born was from a different marriage
different union
i went to get him
i got to his house and i call him
back then
all my my kids have to have a
communication with cell phones
so i could you know
which i call him on his cell phone
and he said dad i just saw you pull up
at his house and i look in my mirror i
watch him walk towards me he was with
student friends
and he said dad can i take
my friends with me i said well you have
to find out from their parent you know
it's okay
i just don't want to take them
so they the boys are trying to call
their parent they couldn't get hear from
their parents i said they are
let me take
let me go to the car wash which is on
the same block and once you reach this
guy's parent
let me know and you just meet me there
so i was the car wash when they came
they were excited and it was okay for me
to take them
uh
i gave them some bus said dad can we
take the bus
my son my kids never
at as close as the school maybe or
wherever they're going we take them
this time around
i'm like you're 14 it's okay i mean to
take the bus you know
it was the holiday weekend
i gave them the money best for whatever
and the [ __ ] i said we'll pick
you up
as soon as they finish washing my car
i watched my son and his friends walk
off and
10 minutes later
i heard
it was buster was close
and
i didn't thought it was my son getting
shot
until one of those little boys his
friend ran back and said
jr no clive
juna got shot
i said junior got shot i mean i'm here
in my head for anything
oh holy that i mean just like that
i got to the scene
like i said there was no police
no parades in there
uh
i can't express to no one
my feelings
how it feels could tell you
i was lifeless
like i didn't know how to
i was like god
just take my life son
[Music]
that stays with me up to this point
why
my son
let me
you know
have had a little bit of life my son
didn't have i mean no connects life
experience that
one would hope for
but um
again
come together with my mom
back home that's a mom
i started to hate god
my mom said
you have no right
you have no right to question god
you know
hello
but i couldn't understand that
until
my um
my then wife
and myself
was been harassed so much
because
my son was killed by a
by the gangs
they were trying to jump my son for the
gangs
my son was fighting back trying to save
himself
and from what the witnesses said
my son had
a hand on him like had him downwards and
then he was with two little boys himself
two other boys
who fighting
my son
friends to the friends these are kids 11
16 or 14.
the boy who killed my son was 17.
so
at that point
my son friend said tells me that
oh he got out
they tried to pull his t-shirt over his
head
but he got out the t-shirt and started
running noticed that the boy
was trying to pull a gun out his waist
too
because my son was doing that and then
he couldn't
and he said
tune around you need to have a gun
my son got off and started running and
he laid there
my son fell in his face
he got up and went over my son and there
was nine more bullets while my son was
laying on his face
my son didn't have a
chance according to the autopsy
there was
seven bullets
that my son picked up that would have
killed it
there was three one was his back the
first one that you maybe would have been
paralyzed
it was one's neck but there was three
that he would
maybe live for a moment while i live but
there were seven
that was that's detrimental
so of course
no he's on the run he was on a run for
to uh uh
to get away from the
law
but that very it was a thursday
there was a teacher
bull came by the murderer
his teacher
was a witness
to the client that she was across the
street
so on
saw the killer
walk by her she was putting gas in her
car and she was
uh
um on antoine you why you're the school
because it was during period of school
and he told her well my other teacher
allowed me to go because i told her i
had something to do
so she said she watched him he did not
even go to the crosswalk he ran across
the street with two other boys and run
and start fighting
this other ball which was my son
and she said
she
he pulled a gun
and trapped my son
his teacher
she said she it was so close to school
that he attended
she said she ran to school without even
moving the car
and told the
principal
oh my god oh my god i just saw
one of our students shot someone
so they recall
this teacher conference right then
and
of course
they went down and reported it
that was thursday but they kept the
principal and the teacher
uh questioning for until friday
morning
you remember they had the america's most
wanted
he was america's most wanted that friday
it was a national war for him
anyway
it happened that um
two weeks has passed and you know they
were still trying to find him and we
were
being harassed by the gang
we have to have police protection
every time we open our door
he needs media
for his apartment every news media
my son became the poster boy against
gang ballings
because my son wasn't again
so
of course you know we um
now we became
[Music]
a part of this whole movement
against game which was
it was a good thing because they every
time they have a conference the police
apartment
we
they want us to be president and for me
it's like
set himself up to get killed you know
anyway
um uh we always leave town we left town
for a while
you know um because of
the threats and you know
and uh my wife was so sick
my present wife she was sick she was
loving all that and we decided she said
i need to go see my doctor
but we're in a town so we
we make an appointment on our way back
we got a call from the police chief then
right
and um
they want us to be president at parker
center
because
the ball wasn't about to turn himself
into
new the channel channel 5 news
because the big day
so we got there they got us there and um
because they would not let him turn
himself in until we were present
got us there
watch the whole thing
he turned himself in
and then he was like
you know questioning why he was on a run
you see he was scared that the police
was gonna kill him
you know
but he deserved to die
you know
that's what i see
by the way we the next day we had an
appointment to
for
my wife
we got there
my wife was pregnant
three weeks pregnant on to date on the
day when my sunglass came
we were like that's not possible we
haven't done nothing you know since last
time but we actually did it right the
same night it was that wednesday night
that my daughter was conceived
within the same 24 hour that's the way i
see it
my daughter was conceived right before
my son got killed
that that's like a
major thing for me to like joy like
thank you god remember i was the guy who
didn't believe in god
[Laughter]
but
here i am now
i have to eat my words and my thoughts
and i understand what my mom was saying
don't question god
that's why i'm a true believer
and even though i'm homeless
everything was taken away from me
he blesses me every day
sometimes to the point where i'm like
but when i got that meal it was so much
that
i was
ever fall asleep right here
and people always say man you're talking
to sleep but what i'm talking about they
always say i said
thank you jesus
in my sleep it's like it happens
moving on this
i can say i've been blessed
my last business opportunity was was my
last restaurant that i had
he blesses me with it
with almost no money
and my restaurant became one of the
biggest restaurants in town
people were lining up every day
mostly on sundays for brunch but we had
a full liquor license we you know it was
the place to be place to go just to go
unwind
i had it for eight years
up until
uh right before right at when the
pandemic came in i this is when i lost
it all
right before
right after i was um
uh the hell's kitchen group came in and
i did a restaurant makeover
and um
again
on top
on top of the restaurant was already
nice to be
much nicer and much more beautiful and
people were like loving it
um
i lost it recently just because of
everything that i said that was
happening
i'm homeless at this point
uh
trying to survive trying to get back
some kind of business
which is would be
food
corner arts that i do i'm a certified
chef
i am
i want to help
i just donate some of my time at the
food bank
you know trying to help
people like myself the ole miss
and
[Music]
my thing moving forward is to
get back
on track
and
[Music]
help those who are helpless
because i know what it feels like
let me say
i did some some drugs to heal my pain
you know and um
i don't consider myself
being
hooked on it because i
i am
that's not what
i live
for um
there's days there's weeks
there's months that i don't even think
about it
but when things get so hard and rough on
like
and then of course you're surrounded
sometimes you know put you in that
frame of mind but
i don't consider myself hooked on drugs
because
i don't focus on that
you know i focus on living and focusing
on helping people by myself
clyde i wish you the best of luck
thank you i think
your life has a strange way of
revolving
yes sir
you get it
thank you
thank you very much
god bless thank you
you